(hip hop music)
- What are you doing?
- I'm doing tricep dips
dude, ever heard of 'em?
- Are you serious, man?
(panting)
I could bet I could do
80 sit-ups right now.
There's people watching
this movie while we plank.
This movie's so great.
Yeah, so I'm kinda seeing this girl.
- Oh, that's cool.
I mean, I've just been hookin' up, so.
- Oh, really, I mean, I've
been hookin' up too, still.
I've actually hooked up
with everyone in this bar.
- That's weird, I also have
hooked up with everyone
in this bar.
- Oh really?
So you know Tracy?
- Yeah, Tracy's a great girl.
This song right here, uhhh.
- Yeah, I like it, but
it's kinda old you know?
This song came out like two weeks ago.
- I'm more into like underground stuff
that you probably have never heard of.
Dj Sweet-N-Low.
- He's all right.
- Off Key?
- Mmm, sometimes.
- Up-Top.
- When I'm in the right mood.
- Man, this splinter in my
finger's just killin' me.
- One time I was straight hammering,
and I hammered a nail
right through my hand.
- I actually just snapped
my whole arm trying
to rescue this three-year old girl.
- I uh, took a bullet for my grandfather.
Three, actually.
- I actually broke my ankle
while I broke a record
for our track team.
- I think I'm done after this one.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, gonna--
- I'm gonna go for a few more, you know?
- Really?
- I'm not feeling good.
- Okay, I'm not feeling good either.
- Penis.
- Penis!
- Oh, she's lookin' over at me.
- Come on, no, she's lookin' at me.
Who's the better dancer?
Come on.
- All right.
- Man, I could plank forever.
I could plank forever.
- Yeah.
You look tired.
- I could do this for hours, dog.
- Yeah, my abs are good.
(panting)
Give me another shot.
Penis.
- Penis.
- Penis!
- I won, dude.
- I won.
- Penis!